[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the Rudolf P Lemone chair and professor
of entrepreneurship at the University of
Maryland as well as the director for the
ed Snyder Center for enterprise and
economics
Rhodri Agarwal welcome to the Rubin
report thank you for having me Dave I
feel we're gonna have a very good talk
because we've already sort of had the
interview before we started we've been
doing it already I'm looking forward to
this because we did meet once before we
were at a conference in DC that was sort
of focusing on academia and free speech
and we spent a couple minutes talking
and what I thought was interesting yeah
I don't think you knew who I was
beforehand and I didn't know who you
were beforehand and they sort of brought
me there to talk a little bit about how
YouTube plays a part and reaching young
people and Technology and all that and
you were very interested in that so we
didn't really focus on free speech
together but we focused on how
technology is shifting the conversation
so just very quickly to start why are
you interested in how technology is
affecting the conversation related to
free speech capitalism the whole thing
so I'm not interested in technology per
se but I'm interested in technology
because it represents the manifestation
of the human mind at work ultimately
what is technology technology is better
machines but what are machines
ultimately whether they're fast
computers or whether they're the
industrialized Age engines or whatever
you call it right they are ways for us
humans to make our lives easier by using
machines so technology ultimately is a
way for humans to communicate better to
live better lives and to use their mind
in doing so yeah so I study innovation I
study technology because it enables us
to be the best we can be by using our
mind I was very proud when you walked in
here because you study innovation and
entrepreneurship and this is Mike
Raaj that we turned into a studio so I
thought yes and think about all of the
creativity that went into it right not
just by you but all of the things all of
the the techniques the machines that
we're looking around it was someone's
mind that had to come up with it first
so creativity which is at the heart of
individual enterprise is what I love and
that's what I study
alright so that's what we're gonna spend
most of this hour talking about and you
know when we do these shows with we're
in Liberty they always send me just a
quick one-page bio on everybody and I
really loved yours there was a bunch of
quotes in there that I that I want to
quote directly to you but you should
know that when they asked me to write
that bio I dished that out in about 15
minutes at 4:30 in the morning oh look
at you patting yourself on the back but
first let's talk a little bit about your
history because you have an interesting
history you were born in India and you
lived there for your first 21 years a
little bit about that well I was born to
a very very traditional family Hindu
family my father was your typical rags
to riches entrepreneur he embodied
enterprise and he in fact I'll tell you
about this one story I was in fifth
grade and I came home so upset because
the history lesson that I had just heard
was all about how the United Kingdom
Britain came in and just plundered this
golden peacock that was India and look
at all the nasty things that they did to
us
and how oppressed and victimized we were
and my father who is a very much of
traditional Orthodox Hindu at that time
said no actually Britain did more good
for India than they did bad and it's
like huh what do you mean by that and he
went on to talk about why before that
it's true that India was rich but what
did rich mean it meant that the Kings
and the traders were rich but there was
a very feudalist economy at that time
and of course they were also very balcan
eyes because each of these kingdoms were
fighting with each other so one of the
things that he talked about is how the
advent of the British you know they
bought the rule of law they bought
infrastructure they gave us English as a
language you know often people my
husband says oh wow you talk better
English than I do and it's like yes
that's because I was educated in English
as well but at the same time that he was
such entrepreneur in his mindset
he was very traditionalist in his views
of how women should be and so when I was
12 years old he said to me the right and
the responsibility of finding a husband
for you is mine don't you forget that
and of course any woman in his family
couldn't work because that was a slap on
his face in his ability to provide for
us but if you think about it at 12 years
old I'm being told that the two biggest
decisions any individual can make for
themselves
will you marry and what you choose to
work in and I and I and I tell you know
I'd like to think that those two
decisions under grid everything that we
do both at work and they're not work
life that we live if those are taken
away from you what does that mean about
you as an individual you as a person
so between 12 and 18 I had to navigate
that distance because at 12 years old I
was a daddy's girl I said of course that
just please do me a favor find me a
husband who lives in Bombay because I
can't even bear the thought of being in
a city that's different from you and at
18 I had to see for myself that I
couldn't renege on that decision so
between 18 and 21 was really my
discovery of who I wanted to be and at
21 I left India two suitcases in my hand
left everybody that I loved a very
generous inheritance my father did not
speak to me for seven years Wow
I mean there's there's so much there of
your formative stuff that leads you to
where you're at right now when you came
home that day in fifth grade you learn
something in school
and then you hear something different
from your father who you obviously
respected and admired and had as you
said rags-to-riches had provided a good
life for you guys how did you go back to
school after that I mean did you go back
and start arguing with teachers is that
even as always arguing with teachers
I've in fact I'd remember my science
teacher saying Rajshri why do you ask so
many wise pretty sure that's not what a
science teacher supposed to say that's
right that's really fascinating so you
picked up and left yes and and left an
inheritance all this you you get to
America just tell me a little bit about
that initial experience so for me this
was freedom it was you know I had lived
in India especially in the generation
that I was in a woman didn't a girl or a
woman did not live by themselves right
they got they stayed with their parents
so they were married and then they went
to their husband's house so the concept
of really being yourself and having the
responsibility to make your own choices
is both liberating but then I also
realize I can't blame my parents for my
mistakes anymore
indeed five years later when my mom or
six years later when my mom came to
visit with us my husband said you know
what is the one biggest difference that
you see in your daughter and this will
tell you a little bit about my
personality there - she says to him
she's become very responsible Wow
that's fascinating action and she's uses
this as evidence she says you know our
her father used to give her a very
generous allowance but we were we would
marvel at the fact that this kid would
go through this allowance within ten or
twelve days and then she'd say I'd like
more and then her father would sometimes
give it and sometimes says no that's all
you're gonna get so then she'd come to
me or she'd come to her brother or I
started to tutor because I often said I
earned my
bread and butter but my father provided
we might put with the jam but one of the
things that she said was now she looks
at me and she realizes just how
responsible I've become that we're
before money would just flow off of my
fingers and I wouldn't give it a second
thought I had become so much more
responsible in my thinking
and I think she was talking a lot more
about than just money in India I was
rebelling mm-hmm because I was fighting
against something I came to the United
States I didn't have to fight against
anything so I had to figure out who I
was and what I really wanted to be yeah
and it allowed me to thrive yeah so you
mentioned you didn't talk to your father
for seven years after that how did the
reconciliation at it or was it a it was
a reconciliation in fact one of the
things that I really really treasure is
you know for the I was a daddy's girl
and I did want his approval and after I
got my PhD I remember this one
conversation that I had with him where I
was this prodigal daughter he was just
finally talking to me again I think he'd
given up on the fact that I would be
this person that would ultimately come
home with my tail between my legs and
say you know you were right I was wrong
he just completely given up on that and
so he was listening to me and of course
I was trying to impress him so I was
talking to him about all of these
achievements as a young assistant
professor I'd received a couple of
awards I was getting to go to these
prestigious conferences and he's
listening but there's silence on his
side and the more I'm talking the more
he's silent and then finally I just gave
I had nothing more to brag about or talk
about and I wasn't getting the I'm so
proud of you from him and so there was
this uncomfortable silence after which
he says it's a phrase in Hindi which
roughly translated says if a peacock
dances in a forest who sees so who cares
and his point to me was you can be all
of the peacock you are but if you're not
next to me it doesn't mean anything so
that was the harshness that we started
but even in the reconciliation but my
last visit with him paradoxically was
when I was asked to give a keynote in
India this was immediately after India's
liberalisation it was thriving as an
economy that we now know it to be and so
I was asked to give a keynote at an
academic conference on entrepreneurship
and economic growth and so on my way to
this conference I stopped by and ten
years after I have done my PhD I'm
finally talking to my father about my
research and connecting it to his own
entrepreneurial spirit and him being a
serial entrepreneur and I can finally
see the pride in his eyes you got I got
there and then at the keynote at the end
of this thing when you go to India you
realize that when you give a speech
they'll give you a present so in front
of about 500 people they give me this
present that I open and believe it or
not it's a peacock seems bidding seems
yes there's so much there and it's so
obvious hearing this story how it led to
all of the things now you're teaching
about now and care about the concept
between the battle between sort of
traditionalism yes and then the
entrepreneurial spirit is really a
fascinating one because he obviously had
that yes he built something for himself
built a good life and then still wanted
that piece of sort of the old world and
I think we all kind of struggle with
that in a way maybe that's what the
struggle of Western civilization is and
I actually think that this relates to
often the need to think and integrate
one psychological growth with one's
growth in the material and in the riches
realm so one of the things that I think
my father was as a paradox unfortunately
and I think that caused him as well as
me so much of this angst between us is
that at the same time that he applied
his intellect into the economic realm he
psychologically did not necessarily
realize that
you know part of the reason he was
successful is because he was able to
make his own decisions which also meant
the freedom to make your own mistakes
and learn from your mistakes
so while he allowed that there as far as
his family was concerned there was this
very protectionist I need to take care
of you right but that I'm realizing this
as a parent is not very conducive to
your children's growth because what you
really need to give them are the tools
to make their own decisions as opposed
to telling them you know this is the way
you should do it yeah and ironically had
you not broken away and been free
although although he may have been very
pleased with your life and who knows
what your life would be and maybe you
maybe you would be happy in some ways it
wouldn't have led you to all this so you
had to directly I have to do that yes so
so one more thing about India before we
move on to everything else you're doing
I told you right before we started that
I get a ton of fan mail from India I
think there's some really interesting
political things happening right there
that seem to be driving people to
watching shows like this just give me
one thing that we should know about
India right now that maybe we don't know
as Americans which i think is probably
probably everything because India never
comes up in the news really yes so so I
I can talk about India right now a
little less than I can talk about the
India that I grew up in and why growing
up in India actually fostered my
entrepreneurial spirit okay so we can do
it a little bit a little bit of that
right and I think that that is one of
the aspects it's definitely selection at
play right I do think that across every
culture people individuals are born
tabula rasa some cultures are much more
conducive to having the entrepreneurial
spirit bloom and as a result you see
people go so much farther but there are
other cult and other cultures stifle it
but as individuals I think we all have
the same proclivity to be the persons
that we can be but one of the things
that I will always credit in my
education in India is the focus on
thinking and critical thinking and
intellectualism
the concept of a nerd growing up for me
was unheard of because the coolest kids
were also the ones that participated in
science and elocution debates you know I
was always at the forefront I wasn't so
much of a sports person but I was very
much in debates in elocution
competitions and science competitions
and so on and that was cool that was
that's right so the concept that there's
a nerd and a nerd is socially awkward
was was unheard off for me I'll give you
another example you know my brother was
the one that first talked to me about
Iran and of course in that journey that
I was telling you about where I had to
find my own identity reading Atlas
Shrugged was really the pillar of
strength and helped me identify my own
sense of life but the way I read Atlas
Shrugged you'd find very funny is in
colleges in India if you're a guy and
you want to impress a chick you carry at
least in my time a paperback novel of
Atlas Shrugged in your back pocket
because that means that you're
intellectually you're thinking now I was
also said it was also said that's right
and it's also said well if you're young
then you believe in these views but then
you grow up and you grow over it
I have never grown over it I think that
that aspect of the mind the ability to
think through decisions is one that I
will credit the Indian culture and my
father for endowing in me yeah well
you'll be happy to know as I mentioned
to you before that you know I was at the
students for Liberty Conference and I
met several students from India who were
there that are involved with Iran
Institute consider themselves
Objectivist and all that and it seems
that some of those ideas at least are
thriving there so yes yes that brings it
into the modern day okay so as I
mentioned I really loved your bio and
there were a couple of great quotes in
there some but I want to read one
directly to you you said my passion is
upward mobility integrated across
intellectual psychological and economic
I care deeply about growth achievement
for me is measured not by the level you
have attained as much as the road you
have traveled for me the journey is the
destination and I care deeply about
integrity as in the whole of a person
rather than the individual parts and I
thought there's obviously a lot there
but it seems to me that this is sort of
what we're missing these days we've got
people that are just screaming at each
other all the time that everyone's
pretending they're an expert in
everything nobody sort of listening you
know I've been travelling with Jordan
Peterson a lot who's talking so much
about what I think is such simple stuff
in a certain way although he's quite
brilliant at it you're talking about
personal responsibility and being a full
person and I thought that that was
really what you were getting to hear yes
so what's the question so the question
is well I guess I sort of know why you
came to believe yes but we seem to have
a real lack of an ability to be a full
integral person these days I think in
part it really relates to this
entrepreneurial mindset and a growth
mindset and for me personally that is a
perspective that is in some sense
selfish let me explain why what I mean
by that and I mean selfish in a very
positive way Here I am right now an
endowed professor I'll just give you an
example of it right and I get to mentor
a lot of young minds and many of them
come to my office particularly PhD
students with this mindset of I know so
much it is true I know a lot but think
about the interaction between a student
and a professor where if the professor
says I know everything you're my student
and you're gonna learn from me it's a
one-way street it's the student
benefiting from the professor with that
mindset but how is the professor
benefiting from it where is my learning
where is my growth so in this
conversation one of the ways that I
approach this relationship is I say you
have
start this conversation thinking of each
other as intellectual equals I may know
more than you but especially in the
realm of research which is creating new
knowledge I need you to have an
questioning mind because what happens if
you're saying something that I want to
challenge and after all in academia
we're in the marketplace for ideas if I
challenge you and your mind immediately
shuts down because you say Oh
Rhodri said this she's the expert
professor she knows everything and
you're not gonna challenge me then
you're not allowing yourself to learn
but more importantly if I know that
about you I'm gonna shut myself down and
I am going to censor myself from
expressing my ideas because I want your
mind to be open so now we both knows and
we've both silenced ourselves so this is
just one example of where I think that
this um this focus on growth and
unlearning is actually very liberating
and in that sense very selfish for me
because now it becomes a two-way street
I'm not just teaching I'm also learning
how do you get over the concept that
selfishness is somehow evil that I think
a lot of people believe this inherently
you say well I'm selfish and they think
well you're evil so this actually
relates to one of this point about the
lack of integration or this thinking
about either/or so the common concept of
selfishness is as in well you're only
thinking about yourself and not thinking
about the other why why does it have to
be an either/or why Cannot it be a
win-win trade which is fundamentally
recognizing your dignity my dignity your
identity my identity and knowledge that
should we've you know right now you and
I are talking why are we sitting here
and having this conversation other than
the fact of course that you know we're
passionate about these ideas and we find
that our time together is meaningfully
well-spent
so my enjoyment
this conversation is not at your expense
neither is what you're gaining out of it
at my expense in fact we're creating
value together yeah I like that you
brought it into this room because that
that's exactly right for me at least
it's like in a way I'm doing something
selfish in that I'm doing my show and
bringing a guest on that you know will
hopefully get people to watch right and
you're here because you want your ideas
to spread the people that are watching
this hopefully are getting something out
of it for themselves I mean that's what
people really need to understand that
that's what's integral about this it
doesn't mean we're taking from you it
actually means that we're giving side to
ourselves and something yes and so for
me this notion that selfishness means
this brute that is just gonna ride
roughshod over everybody else's rights
and responsibilities fundamentally does
not get to this idea that each of us
have a right to live our lives the way
we see best and you know take the
consequences good or bad all far
decisions how much of this do you think
is about just whether people view humans
fundamentally as good or evil so if you
fundamentally think people are evil and
you say to someone be selfish well then
it is that they're gonna run roughshod
over everybody and destroy the
environment and steal money and kill
people and all that versus if you
believe people are fundamentally good or
at least neutral then if they do
something for themselves it will
potentially be so for me the only evil
is really the use of force to throttle
somebody else you can do what you want
to do so long as you're not infringing
on other people's rights and
responsibilities and their ability to
live their life the way they do and
indeed in a civil society that is the
fundamental respect that we all each
other that I live my life the best way
that I think is done but I'm not gonna
impose my views on you I may have a
conversation with you about my views and
you're free to agree or disagree with my
views and free to agree
to interact or not with me but I can't
force my views and my beliefs on you and
neither should you force I mean that's
fundamentally the conversation between
my from my father and I think about it
right it is that we were both very
aligned when our views 80% of the time
but the 20% where he thought that as a
father he had the right to tell me what
I should do as opposed to be the
facilitator and guide an adviser to my
decisions that is the fundamental
disconnect do you think we spend too
much time on that 20% or you know I
think I heard Barry Weiss on real time
called the narcissism of small
difference yes where we we can agree on
almost everything
yes philosophically and then we find
something yes and then that is what we
focus on and it really depends upon is
that something in a hierarchy of your
values a fundamental issue that you do
need to disagree on or is that something
in the hierarchy of your values and your
beliefs something that is not as
critical to the conversation that we're
having so I prefer indeed I am a big
believer in win-win outcomes I don't you
know my husband is my best friend I love
him the last thing I would want is for
him to say rah Shri I'm with you not
because it gives me any selfish joy not
because I get any pleasure I take pity
on you I feel sorry for you and that's
why my life's objective is to take care
of you but do you want to be in that
relationship I walk out the door I'd say
if I am NOT giving you personal
satisfaction and joy in being with me if
I'm not your best friend just like your
mind then this relationship is not a
win-win yeah and I don't want to be
either an object of charity or to or
pity or I don't want you to feel like
you're obligated yeah so I want to back
up to something you said a few minutes
ago about the way that you teach and
that exchange between professor and
student where it's it's sort of you
trying to look at each other as you
and I might learn something from them
and they might learn something for me so
so two parts of that first of how often
do you find that you actually learn some
tools every time indeed last year
University of Maryland honored me with
the distinguished scholar teacher award
and one of my first slides was about
exactly that the debt that I owe to my
advisor who incidentally gave me away
when Rob and I got married remember my
father wasn't talking to me my advisor
was my second father and so I learned a
lot from him and I have benefited from
that learning of a mentor advisor
relationship but I have benefited
equally from paying it forward so every
one of my PhD students I can pinpoint to
you exactly what ideas they helped me
learn which empirical context and
innovative industries I went into along
with them and how my own scholarship has
fundamentally benefited and even changed
trajectories because of my PhD students
so the second part of that then would be
do you think that is a real rarity on
college campuses these days that that
professors are willing to learn from
students because when I go to colleges
which I'm doing all the time now one of
the things I hear most is that students
are actually afraid to challenge their
professors because they think it's going
to hurt their grades and that generally
just generally speaking this seems to
come from more leftist professors that
if you challenge them on
intersectionality or any of that that
they at people actually think their
grades will suffer do you think that
that's a problem in academia it is
unfortunately I you know I there's this
part of me in my soul that says that
just cannot be true
please let this not be true because the
fundamental identity of an academic
should be one which is focused on
learning and focused on ideas and indeed
I would say that one requires a
confidence and a self-esteem and to be
comfortable with being challenged and
so often I do have several colleagues
that I worry about in as much as they
don't make good advisors and part of the
reason they don't make good advisors is
not because they are not experts in
their sphere but precisely because they
cannot stand being challenged by their
students and in my opinion that's a
lose-lose not only are you steaming the
students growth you're signing your own
growth yeah so when you hear people
talking about the free speech issues on
college campuses and at the conference
that we were at I mean there were
literally hundreds of professors there
to talk about how do we defend free
speech that was the whole purpose of it
do you sense that something has shifted
in the last couple years does it seem
worse now I'll give you my own personal
story about three years two years ago I
ended up writing an op-ed in the
Washington Post on confessions of a
silenced professor now you've heard me
these last 15 20 minutes anyone that
knows me says rush reuse silence
give me a break easily silence exactly
and indeed part of the theme of that
op-ed was a very important
self-realization that I had and that was
that I was now starting to think do I
really want to take this on and it was a
colleague of mine who we were just
having a conversation about something
that had happened at a conference and
she said to me when I was like you know
I'm wondering should I weigh in on this
or should I just let it go
and the point is not what the issue was
the point is that I even asked that
question which is what this colleague
said to me she says Rajshri when did you
become so afraid of speaking your mind
and that really hit me in my gut if you
will it's like when did I start thinking
if I do this what's going to be to fall
out within the academic circles should i
repress myself and that's when I
realized that the spiral of sight
where we end up so you know you can talk
about censorship I actually think of the
University of Maryland I am in a great
university president on down we have a
investment and a dedication towards
freedom of speech and thinking about the
academia as a marketplace for ideas so
great to hear it I mean I just before I
came here I had a phenomenal
conversation with the president
regarding an event where we're worried
about whether or not there is going to
be some backlash because of some of the
people that we're bringing in in a
debate but for us it's very important to
have that reasoned and respectful
discourse but for me it was you know
people from the outside can tell you
whatever they want but when you start to
silence yourself that's when you silence
your mind that's when you don't let your
innovative creativity you know what is
freedom of speech about it is not the
freedom to agree it's the freedom to
disagree but doing so in a manner and
again coming back to this use of force
right I can say what I want I am NOT you
know III in college campuses these days
one of the things that they say is well
words can hurt you know I was in a
convent and the teachers used to say
sticks and stones can break my bones but
words don't hurt me right and yes words
do have a power I'm not denying that for
sure several of the things that my
father said to me psychologically were
very wounding and I had to work through
that so I'm not denying the fact that
words in the psychological and
intellectual realm are very powerful but
the point is as a fundamental difference
between words and coercion as in now I
am forcing you to think otherwise
because words are fundamentally our
minds thinking and then communicating
with each other yeah we've had a long
sort of slippery road on this right
where people's are starting to think
that words mean action or that you have
some sort of right to not be offended or
a right to comfort I mean you just
simply don't have those
I think actually it's the converse is
true you need to be courageous to look
at something and say this doesn't accord
with my beliefs so you know they let me
use a different analogy out here people
often talk about open versus closed mine
I actually think neither of those
concepts makes sense because what is a
closed mind that is the professor that
you and I were just talking about who
says I'm right how dare you challenge me
I've made up my decisions already right
but an open mind is someone that's just
sitting on the fence not willing to take
any kind of a committed stand in fact I
would prefer a closed mind to an open
mind in that way right but what I really
care about is an active mind that I have
some opinions some beliefs and they're
based on the prior thinking that I have
done but I'm not omniscient
I'm not infallible I could have made
mistakes in my thinking so having an
active mind allows me the gives me the
permission to say I do have these
thoughts and beliefs but if someone
provides me with compelling evidence and
compelling logic that would make me
change my thinking then it isn't my best
interests to do so yeah you know it's
funny I find I often I sit across
brilliant people all the time and every
now and again someone dropped something
that I think wow that's what I've been
trying to get to active mind I mean I'm
gonna start using that phrase because
that's right you don't just want an open
mind of of endless nothing actually and
you don't want to close my but an active
mind keep keyboarding - thank you Dan
yeah so I want to ask you one other
thing on this and then I really want to
focus on all the stuff that you're
teaching yes for the whole second half
um what do you think the actual solution
is related to this so if a professor
like you has this sudden need or fear of
self censoring and I think it's pretty
obvious to me how open and and
courageous you are inherently what do
you think the solution is and when we
were at this conference a lot of the
professor's were saying this has to
come from the donors because the
administrators at the schools cannot be
brave enough if they think that their
jobs are on the line all the time but
that the one way to do it is that if the
donors are slowly turning off the money
to professors that won't defend free
speech or administrators who won't back
the professors who do that that might be
the change does that make sense to you
yes and I disagree with it let me
explain to you why I disagree with it oh
you cannot so this comes back to the
first question you asked me why do I
focus on integrity and why do I think
about economics which is money and
donors along with psychological and
intellectual growth for me you cannot
have one without the other
these are pieces of an Intel that that
fit together to make an integrated whole
within academia one always has to worry
about the fact that you've got all of
these pressures Russians for conformity
pressures for funding and resources that
are coming in there what you really care
about and which you cannot renege if you
are an intellectual entrepreneur which
is truly what being an academia is all
about being an intellectual entrepreneur
is your unwavering focus on knowledge
creating knowledge and if I if I may say
so on truth resources just like any
venture capitalist so this intellectual
entrepreneur may be a good analogy
actually venture capitalists provide you
with the financial resources but they
are complimentary resource providers
they cannot tell you which direction
should you go nor should they right if
you don't have that creative mindset
that intellectual horsepower if you're
not courageous enough to go for that
then any kind of pressure from the
venture capitalists is not gonna help
nor are any kind of pivots and
directions and so on so the way I look
at it is I do not
will not ever change my research based
on what donors may or may not give on
the contrary I will look for aligned
donors because you cannot put the cart
before the horse
you cannot put your purpose behind the
money or the success metrics of your
purpose your purpose has to drive all of
the other resources that you garner so
if an administrator lacks courage that's
on the administrator first and foremost
if an academic lacks courage of
conviction that's on them you can have
complimentary people aligned with you
kind of helping you along the way but
they cannot substitute for that
fundamental Drive that you need to have
[Music]
you
[Music]